hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leet and in this video of course
i wanted to wish you a merry merry
christmas and a happy
new year i have got the most insane
christmas gift which i'm going to be
giving somebody in form of a competition
so thank you so much for a great year
this has been a great year i know for
some people it's been tough
million people have lost their jobs this
year it's been tough i don't know what
you're doing right now
i don't know where you are but i want to
say i wish you very very well and i hope
you're having a really blessed and jolly
christmas now 2021 i want as many people
in 2021
to become financially free we've
realized this year in 2020
we cannot rely on the government
we can't we cannot rely on
employers we can't we can only rely on
ourselves
and the most lucrative way to make money
and to stand on your own two feet as an
entrepreneur is
through property investment that's the
strongest way
every single week i have someone come
and win us on a wednesday even during
the christmas period
even during the lockdown they're coming
on winners on a wednesday
and they're telling their story of how
my training programs
help them become financially free i've
just
finished the eviction which by the way
is going to be coming out tomorrow and
i'm so
excited the eviction if you don't know
was when i
had 10 people move into my house
now with covert restrictions it was
slightly different but i worked with 10
people
throughout a whole month set them
challenges
and the weakest link after each
challenge was evicted
and the strongest person that lasted
through the whole month
i did a financial freedom challenge with
them this
show it's like the apprentice but for
property it's incredible
it's coming out tomorrow it's just such
a brilliant
show you're going to love it you're
going to be entertained you're going to
learn lots however how does this affect
you
how are you going to benefit from this
here's my gift okay this is crazy right
now
every single training program that i
have the lease option boot camp the hmo
bootcamp the serviced accommodation
intensive
the rent to rent accelerator the buy
refurbished refinance master class
all of my of my property training
programs
the same programs that help so many
people become financially free
i am going to be giving away i'm going
to be giving them away
on the 30th of december that's just a
few days time
and and this isn't just i'm not going to
give it to one person i'm going to give
it to
one person and their friend or their
partner
so how do you enter into the competition
it's very very simple all you need to do
head down to my instagram leeds.samuel
i'll leave a link in the description
my latest post on instagram where i'm
wishing everybody a merry christmas
standing right in front of this
christmas tree say merry christmas all
you need to do
is like the post and in the description
or in the comment box on instagram tag
the friend
that you want to become financially free
tag them
and use the hashtag so tag your friend
and then put hashtag
the eviction that's it and
you might be selected along with the
friend that you tagged
and you can tag as many friends as you
want and the more times you tag people
the more likely that you're going to be
selected because it's just a piece of
software that just
randomly picks one person and the person
that wins
all you need to do is just go down to my
instagram post like the post
comment your friend's name and use the
hashtag the eviction do as many times as
you want
tag as many friends as you want and the
winner i am going to
transport permitting drive to your house
and i'm going to present you with the
prize which will unlock you to
all of the training programs and help
you become
financially free throughout the year of
2021.
so that's the gift it's kind of crazy
it's it's worth
6 000 pounds worth of training and
i just want to see somebody become
financially free from youtube
you know i don't even want you to have
to pay i just want you to become
financially free
times are tough so get down to instagram
obviously you need to follow me make
sure you subscribe to the youtube
channel
drop a like drop a comment and i'm going
to be choosing somebody
on the 30th of december and that's going
to be announced
so the eviction comes out tomorrow
boxing day episode one then episode two
episode three episode four episode five
back to back
the eviction finishes on the 30th
of december you're gonna love the
eviction
you are gonna love it i hope you're
watching and i hope you're following i
hope to see you commenting
on the 30th of january of december the
30th of december
in the description to the final of the
eviction i'm going to announce the
winner
i'm going to announce the winner and i
think it's going to be you so get down
to instagram
like my latest post tag your friends use
the hashtag the eviction
and i look forward to hopefully coming
around your house very very soon
giving you all the training you need to
unlock your financial freedom
i'm stoked merry christmas happy new
year
i'll see you on instagram